[Music]
one
[Laughter]
hey you guys
they're like what are you guys doing at
sidetracks on sunday what the [ __ ] is
going on is it the end times doesn't
matter it doesn't matter well it's
because
we went out last night and we didn't get
a chance to watch a movie so we didn't
have a movie to talk about so i said
[ __ ] it we'll just do another sidetrack
show plus on friday night sidetrack show
you were falling asleep and like left
before
oh pat pat [ __ ] contacted me
sent me a send me a dm said that was the
best show of all time
he said to him and his wife are [ __ ]
laughing
i started kind of nodding out jenny's
[ __ ] getting [ __ ] on me
and then [ __ ] khan is like man once
you pack up your [ __ ] get the [ __ ] off
the audience kicked me off of the show
i was like yeah
yeah
we had caught up to me you know i mean
i've been drinking all day
yeah that'll
happen and you've been drinking all day
and then like you're kind of you kind of
like you weren't he's like crabby but
you were kind of like not really with it
yeah you know what i mean you're just i
slept for an hour and then woke up and
did the show yeah
and i never really could wake up and uh
you know because i was looking
inebriated
but it what happens with me is like um
either i crash and fall asleep
or i'll just if i if i keep the [ __ ]
dosage level over a long period of time
i just won't be able to stay awake yeah
you know that's so that i couldn't stay
awake and then jenny she's getting all
[ __ ] hyper she's enjoying the show
yeah i was having a good time three
hours into this [ __ ] i'm going man man i
gotta get off the show it wasn't even
three hours i don't think it was only
like two and a half hours it'd only make
it like two hours
not to make it like two hours
it happens man that's you never know
what's going to happen on this show
real
we never know either she'll talk [ __ ]
about me probably i didn't even hear it
i didn't talk about talking [ __ ] about
me that's not worth this [ __ ]
being on the show i'm pretty sure i
[Laughter]
i'm pretty sure i would have remembered
if that happened all right i don't think
i said anything mean about you after i
was just kind of like oh well
and uh yeah i think i just answered a
couple questions and i don't well
because i don't mind being i don't know
i don't mind being on the live show by
myself but it's it's a lot easier like
when you're here the con of ocelon's in
there right now man he was he's already
hit the great reset he was eating
[ __ ] crickets today because look what
i'm eating he's down in mexico eating
[ __ ] broiled crickets
i thought that was kind of a thing
that's a thing they eat in mexico yeah i
know that's what i'm saying and uh
he's telling me you know is there any
seasoning on those things you know he's
another like shrimp you know he'd eat
him a whole wings at all
yeah i've heard they taste kind of
shrimpy yeah i
i couldn't eat that around my dad and my
dad would [ __ ] get mad man don't eat
that
don't eat what are you eating crickets
that's bait
he eats everything
my dad would be like every one of them
crickets i can catch a fish with step
aside give him
step aside you don't you do it you think
i will turn that whole
uh turn that hole i'll turn that whole
bag of crickets into a whole bucket of
fish hold on what kind of sun did i
raise yeah yeah yeah yeah
this ain't thailand
and that's how my dad saw my dad
i can imagine it i can imagine it that
was in the navy he's good thailand a lot
he's on the yorktown this is your time
that's some good [ __ ] down there as we
would say
that's how much you pay for oh not much
not much you didn't pay much
he's a sailor you know it's real
reasonable yeah
reasonably priced [ __ ]
just pull up report and just start
buying plus
not buying it ran it you know
that would be a funny shirt too
reasonably priced [ __ ] yeah although i
don't like if a girl wears it you might
get yourself into trouble so yeah
yeah
dj
tell me a story one time he was he was
in uh i don't remember it was thailand
or
or [ __ ] philippines i think it was
philippines
and uh he goes in the bar he starts
getting drunk and [ __ ] there's girls
in there and he's he and his buddy were
having a [ __ ]
good time [ __ ] shooting the [ __ ] with
the bartender
and bartender [ __ ] steps off and some
girls get up on him like that he starts
making out this hot girl in the [ __ ]
bartender cuz he goes no no no no no
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
what [ __ ]
reached down there just [ __ ] god he's
like
nah so what you're trying to tell me is
your dad knows all there is to know
about the crying game i guess
yeah bartender saved him [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey maybe your dad was into that don't
judge
i don't think he would i'm just kidding
uh he would have told me his story
that's true it would have just been like
whatever yeah um dj maniac was talking
about how he got vampire's kiss the dvd
for a dollar 25 at dollar tree yeah we
really need to do that movie one of
these days he says no commentary no
commentary track that's a shame uh gotta
wait for the blu-ray coming out it's
like man i want to watch that again
that's movies bat [ __ ] insane nicholas
cage is batshit insane somebody was
saying
somebody said they wanted me to see the
mommy yeah the brandon fraser one i told
you you would like them i don't have it
you would like them
there's just two right isn't it just the
mummy and the mummy returns yeah
somebody sends them to me on dvd or
blu-ray i'll watch
ooh he's pimping for free [ __ ] yeah yeah
you gotta pick i can pivot it out
um but no what yeah what why would i
like them
i don't know it just seems like the kind
of thing that you would like it's kind
of like a funny it's like an adventure
it's kind of like um i'm trying to think
of something like recent that it's i've
never heard him well it's kind of like
it's indiana jonesy but it's all like
kind of funny too like they're really
just entertaining they're like just
action adventure type movies okay i
never even heard them yeah
um
what was i gonna say oh speaking of old
people because you're talking about your
dad can we talk about the the lady at
the restaurant yeah yeah
man i was sitting there [ __ ] we went
to oyster trough again yesterday for
lunch
we were the first people in in there
pretty much yeah we got there at like 11
30. yeah right when it opened right when
it opened and then all of a sudden a
whole bunch of other people showed up
and they were all old people
so we hit we hit the old wave
all right we'll see old people always go
early that's why i'm always kind of like
weirded out by going really like i like
to go really early because it's not
crowded but i was like that's
that [ __ ] that old people do yeah it's
like you know what i mean they'd like
the early bird specials and all that
kind of crap yeah yeah but they don't
have that there no i know but i'm just
saying that old people like to go shoes
and have meals early but we're old
people too i guess because because we
did the exact same thing
[Laughter]
you know i'm looking at jenny and all of
a sudden this couple comes in and this
dude's holding this woman back and she's
dragging him across the floor
and she's going hello hey i love you and
i'm going what what the [ __ ] is going on
and it looks like she was getting ready
to fall over and the dude's grabbing her
like that and she
busts away and drags him across about
five feet and she grabs a hold of jenny
starts kissing her on the side of the
face god i love you i love you and i was
just the [ __ ] is going on because i'm
looking at her like do i know these
people yeah what the [ __ ] who are you
and she and he pulls her away and then
they go to she gets to be all over my
face and it's like who are you she goes
i love her i kissed her
what the [ __ ] and and realized that
she's just [ __ ] out of her mind with
some kind of um dimension
yeah
she was just telling everybody that she
loved everybody and um
she was
she looked normal you wouldn't know
just looking she was with her husband
and there was one other older like one
of their old guys trying to keep her at
the table
yeah because she kept wanting to like
run around and run around say hi to
everybody and say hi to everybody yeah
and she's i love you i love you like
every time the the waitress walks by i
love you darling yeah yeah yeah i love
you too
[Laughter]
it was so weird yeah yeah they came in
like what but yeah it was just i didn't
see them come in because i was sitting
with my back to the door so i guess you
saw them come in but like all i knew was
like all of a sudden this this huge old
lady face was like in my face and she's
like grabbing me and like kissing the
side of my face and stuff and i'm like
who is this woman i'm like who are you
well for a second i thought maybe i knew
her yeah you know what i mean like maybe
it's a teacher or somebody i used to
work with or something like that but i
was like who is this i can't place it
she was at vermont yeah i didn't realize
that until like a couple seconds later
so i was like well that was entertaining
but uh yeah so she was almost combative
you know
yeah she's trying to you know if she
wanted to do it she was gonna do it
whether they were [ __ ] two or three
people holding her down or not
and she wouldn't even complain about
being held down she'd just continued to
fight and go in that direction yeah
she's like i'm going this way yeah i'm
going over here and going over here and
they're holding her back
and the old men aren't they didn't warn
me yeah like
she was pulling one of them across the
[ __ ] road and i'm going what the [ __ ]
is going on here they're like a dog on a
leash just pulling it just like that
and he didn't go he didn't go watch out
she's you know got dementia
that just i had i was forced to figure
that out on my own so he's not warning
me or anything you know
i'd be like watch out she's lost her
mind
she's on a ramp
[Laughter]
it was pretty [ __ ] crazy once they
got her in the booth she was all right
though yeah they were they sat at the
table like right behind you of course so
we could hear her she'd be talking
saying the same things over and over
again yeah she just kept saying the same
thing and then she was asking him about
his wife and that was his wife yeah she
was asking her husband about his wife
yeah
and he he
she forgot that he
that that she thought she was single
[Laughter]
yeah it was pretty weird it was pretty
weird yeah she thought she was a single
one they did yeah they came in a little
bit after us but um and the the
restaurant is short staffed so they um
they were pretty slow yeah and but they
had a sign on the front that said hey
we're short staffed because one of the
well they said the owner that was
usually there he was had to do something
else but then he came later
and um so they were like so it's gonna
be a little while they were warning
everybody but it's like they they gave
them their food first because i guess
they wanted to get them out of there as
quickly as possible so that was like
fine with me yeah he um
i had that white fish dinner
it was fried fish it was like fish and
chips yeah but i didn't have chips i
just had onion rings and hush puppies
man [ __ ] was good
yeah it's like 14 bucks i gotta well i
got a white fish sandwich yeah with
french fries
and i was thinking it was gonna be like
a sandwich like maybe a little bit
bigger than
like a mcdonald's sandwich
it comes there and the piece of
whitefish is literally this big yeah
almost a foot long and it was like and
it's laying across this like hoagie roll
like toasted hoagie roll i couldn't i
had to eat it with a knife and fork i
couldn't pick it up like a sandwich and
eat it but it was and i also couldn't
finish it i had to bring half of it home
and eat it later because it was just i
was like i'm not complaining because it
was delicious i'm just saying i didn't
expect it to be that big the trough
the oyster trough yeah t-r-o-f-f yeah
it's in it's in what's the name of that
place lake lake mary uh
wait is it mount dorado mountain i think
it's mount dora yeah i think it's
mountain it's only a couple miles up the
road here yeah i think i can all
remember how many miles away it is but
yeah there's not much to look at just
the damn lime green
old old diner looking yeah we showed
that we showed that video of it it's the
first time that we went yeah they got
good food in there real good oh and i
had um i had oyster chowder too yeah and
that tasted like yeah it smelled really
good it didn't it they had it had like
whole like oysters in there it wasn't a
little like chopped up stuff and it
tasted like fresh like they had just
made it
but yeah it was like it was really good
so yeah we did that
and then
we went to mannequins last night
and that was a lot of fun yeah i mean
we'll see what they tried to do before
the sort of more goth industrial night
is friday night at mannequins saturday
night is the same dj
um but for a long time it was called
what the [ __ ] saturdays
where they would just basically play
anything like anything anybody asked for
so it's like if you want to play like
the bg's or something like you know it's
whatever or metal or whatever
but uh since eyebar
barbarella
is not uh downtown anymore since they
moved locations
so mannequins is now trying to get the
eyebar saturday night crowd
so the music is going more which i'm
happy about the music is actually going
more in a 80s
new wave post punk direction
uh so the music last night was
outstanding i think i danced to like
[ __ ] i don't know i danced like
almost every song
like once that man he was playing like
so much good [ __ ]
he played the [ __ ] he played the
cramps and he played [ __ ]
um
that [ __ ] uh he played a bunch of
echo in the body man
and
like some wit like weird like he played
telegram sam like the bauhaus song i was
like wow i've heard that in forever in a
club it's you know and but yeah he just
played all kind of really good [ __ ] it
was really really good music
yeah they're getting
hornet harness and the kind of eyes on
islander and they're talking they're
both talking about t.j
um
looking hornet's saying that [ __ ]
gabe's busting his balls he goes he
crosses the border
to do work down there he's an american
that works in tijuana or goes there a
lot he lives right on the border
and um
fights with the border bombs one of them
names gabe and he [ __ ] records it
puts it on his channel you see you just
go over there and gabe is the border
bomb yeah he's just a bomb at the border
and he fights with him and [ __ ] it is
hilarious
bum begs from him he's not really a bum
he's he's kind of like what they would
call in brazil what they call a tour
guide he's a dude that [ __ ] hangs out
around the taxi stands where foreigners
show up and tries to hook you up with
girls or bars or just anything you need
he's the local guy the local guide who
guy who kind of guides you i guess
you know he's one of those type of dudes
they're just kind of a jack-of-all-trade
just a
dude trying to make money off of you
and then they're going there saying that
a bunch of ukrainian white girls are
[ __ ]
being refugees and hopping the border
right now i didn't know about that it's
getting warm in here yeah it is getting
kind of warm and think about turning in
well it was cold earlier that's why i
put my little jacket on it's actually
was nice last night it was
when we left mannequins i think it was
like 48 degrees
it was nice and cool those coyotes are
going to make a whole lot of money off
them white women they're worth a lot of
money
they're going to be selling them
i wouldn't [ __ ] go down there
i don't stand in ukraine
noel says jenny did you ever eat a
traditional british breakfast when you
were there yes i did many times
um
some you know what i have to say one of
the weirdest things of pertaining to
breakfast in the uk and i know this
isn't the traditional english or the
full english or whatever because i
actually really do like that it's not
that different from mars it's just a
couple different things but one of the
weirdest things that i saw people eating
for breakfast over there was like canned
spaghetti on toast
yeah
terrible and i was like that's not even
good
for lunch i mean much less
i i couldn't face eating that for say in
the morning
or that because a lot of meat beans on
toast too
i mean i guess it's not weird in other
parts of the world like to eat that for
breakfast like to eat beans for
breakfast
but
i don't know i guess to an american it's
weird
because we have
a particular kind of
breakfast food and that's what yeah
there are a lot of ukrainians here now
okay
how much do they want for one
why why are you in the market yeah i'll
buy a couple of them yeah
yeah
oh i have them around here working doing
yard work and [ __ ]
what you doing
pookie's got her uh
oh my goodness
she can see her she's got her she's got
her mint toy
and she's just
then like kicking it with her back feet
and stuff she loves that [ __ ] thing
that one's getting kind of grubby i have
to get her i have a new one on a card
over there but i'm not going to give it
to her until that one's torn out yeah
you know fun
khan's saying that the mexican dudes are
buying them up
yeah baked beans on toast
yeah
yeah i think beans on toast was more
common but i did see some people eating
like spaghetti onto like canned
spaghetti onto it's like [ __ ]
not even chef boyardee it was kind of i
think it was hines
because that's we have heinz over here
too but that's like a it's a big brand
over there like the beans and everything
no beans or jam yeah
i don't know i just i don't
i don't consider beans of breakfast food
no that's something that that's
something that came up out of
desperation yeah
that's just because that's what they had
in england they were eating bean canned
beans no seasoning or anything and what
they're talking about is they're talking
about those canned beans in the tomato
sauce that's kind of like what we would
call beanie weenie but without the
weenie
it's just beanie
and then they're [ __ ] pouring that on
a plate and trying to eat that for
breakfast i [ __ ] feel bad for him why
would you put why would you put it over
like toast to make your toast all soggy
yeah terrible idea that's grody
that shit's only good for one thing for
making baked beans
what you do
with that beanie
i could see the canopy [ __ ] weenie
not that the weenie and it makes it
better no it really does doesn't really
make it much better
okay what you do is you open you empty a
couple of those cans in a big old glass
bowl that's that's that's oven safe
you might want to put four cans in there
and put a couple big old heaping
tablespoons
of [ __ ]
dill relish or sweet relish you can put
that in there and then like two
tablespoons of yellow
french's mustard you know
put that in there and then about a half
a [ __ ] cup or between a half a cup to
a cup of brown sugar in it
and then make squeeze a little bit of
ketchup in it maybe like a tablespoon or
two
and then stir it all together
and bake it and reduce it down so it
becomes thick
when it comes out it'll be real good it
uh it'll it'll be darker you'll kind of
have a sweetness to it
um
you won't taste the relish or the
mustard or any of that really it all
just kind of vanishes it just kind of
blends in together you take that you
scoop it out of the bowl out of that big
bowl and you put it into a smaller bowl
or a side you know like it's a side dish
and put a dollop of sour cream on it
it's good
yeah that's what you do with that other
than that
the other thing that you do with those
cans of beans is you take that can of
bean you put it in your right hand you
throw that [ __ ] in the [ __ ] garbage
that's just good
or throw it at someone you don't like
yeah optionally yeah
you use that to throw it at the [ __ ]
riot police in the [ __ ] riot carrying
that cat
it's part of their trade craft because
they can't [ __ ] they can't [ __ ]
charge you for carrying a weapon if it's
food
so yeah like what it's just a can of
beanie weenies without the weenies well
okay
i'm gonna start talking about [ __ ]
survival food and [ __ ] well hang on hang
on i want to like
because i wanted to say like tila is
here
and says you guys are doing sidetracks
on sunday i'm like yeah it's just
because we went out last night and we
didn't we're not drunk right now i
promise uh we may be hungover but not
not drunk and yes
and uh i got kicked off my own show like
uh [ __ ]
uh friday yeah friday i got kicked off
my own show i didn't kick you off the
crowd kicked me off the con kicks so you
can't blame that one said tom what you
just gonna leave the show
yeah go to bed old man
yeah
as soon as i left all the [ __ ] super
chat started coming bing bing
[Laughter]
said you didn't get kicked off i was
there you left my bro yeah
yeah i blamed in them
he can't take responsibility for his own
actions it always has to be [ __ ] he
blames it he does it's jokingly but he
blames me for like pretty much
everything yeah
so that's how my mind worked yeah you
did it i'm like look i wasn't even here
what are you talking about
it's genetic so yeah so now like i
started doing that to pookie like every
time something happens like the power
goes out or something pokey what did you
do
i didn't do it
okay yeah but um yeah that's what we're
doing because we went out last night and
so we didn't uh watch a movie we didn't
have a movie to talk about
and then tila said jenny you look pretty
thank you
last night i had
a guy
um
who wanted me to teach him how to dance
yeah that was [ __ ] funny
he was like trying to hit on me later
and then he was talking about how old he
was and i'm like bro how old are you and
he said 38 i was like
you don't know from old [ __ ]
[Laughter]
like i'm way i'm way older than you
good night though i mean that that club
is uh
is popping off oh it's we got there at
like 9 30 and it was already
half full and then it was just like
[ __ ] packed yep it was packed last
night
man i went down to publix today and
there's [ __ ] it's getting expensive
and it's getting expensive to buy food
all that shit's true what they're saying
18 eggs was five dollars
a couple months ago man it was like
two dollars
um you could get a dozen eggs for like a
dollar dollar something here
have you gone through have they
restocked at the dollar general because
i thought yeah they're not restocking
hardly over there well see i saw him
restocking stuff the other day and then
i saw a cookie i saw it well not cooked
that's all that matters i'm just going
to look at those cookies no cookies god
damn it yeah um but
yeah i saw him restocking some stuff and
then
when we were coming back from oyster
trough i saw a big dollar general semi
that was heading to the store so i'm
assuming they were bringing new [ __ ] but
i don't know i haven't been there in a
couple of days cheese is high eggs are
high over there the only thing that's
still kind of low is like their wonder
bread is still a dollar for a loaf but
the name brandt's that was stuff is like
a dollar fifty dollar sixty
um
no and and a lot of the selection is
going away
a little pack of um
i'm doing like alternate stuff like a
little pack of pepperoni they wanted
five dollars for that
um
i think a jimmy dean sausage you know
the little ones are only that big
i think it was you could get two for
eight dollars
that's not a good price those things
were a dollar ninety
you know you know what i learned that
that is actually called a chub the chub
yeah
i deal with it on a daily basis well i
thought i was watching one of those one
of those uh video like those extreme
budget like we're going shopping at
dollar tree and like making like a
week's worth of food for 10 or whatever
and
one of them had said they bought one of
those little jim eating sausage things
for a dollar and they called it a chub
and i'm like are they just calling it
that like to be funny or but then i saw
another unrelated video that also said
that i'm like oh i guess that's what
they're called i never knew that yeah
that sounds dirty
it's a chub of sausage yeah
gas is still kind of reasonable here
it's not it's not six dollars a gallon
like it isn't we got some last night but
i didn't notice how much it was it was
yeah i didn't even look
because we only we only put like 10
bucks in it because we don't i mean we
don't drive that much no we don't drive
that much but we put some in last night
because we were going to mannequins so
my motorcycle gets real good both of my
bikes get really good gas mileage so i
don't have to worry about that much if i
really have to go somewhere i can ride
that
um
if it gets rough
but um
no man i'm starting to look at the damn
local farms
we passed that local farmer again he's
[ __ ] selling chickens and eggs and
dead rabbits
i get you know right he's growing
rabbits in there um
he had all kinds of i'm just going to
i'm just going to start getting a
relationship with those dudes well yeah
you said you'd probably get they are
yeah what they have
because i want to see how much a rabbit
is
rabbits grow quickly
and chickens you can if
if the hoa allow chickens they don't
allow chickens but if this [ __ ] [ __ ]
starts getting real bad people are gonna
start asking to have chicken coops
i'll have some chickens are easy to take
care of
they just let them out during the day
[ __ ] hawks get some of them but they
they breed quickly
and every day you get a [ __ ] ton of eggs
you can't even keep up with the eggs
i used to take care of dr matt's
chickens
he must have had about 10 chickens
10 15 chickens
and uh it was almost two dozen eggs it
seemed like to be about a dozen eggs a
day yeah because they were just like
what they were free range and wandering
around like laying eggs all over the
place i couldn't find all the damn eggs
yeah you had to yeah you'd have to go
like searching for them like a [ __ ]
easter egg hunt yeah they're laying eggs
they're they're laying eggs inside the
[ __ ] horse feeders
eggs in there and then the chickens want
to fight no no no no no no no no
yeah yeah they're trying to sit on the
egg
no no no no
funny man
they had one they had one feeder i
didn't know about
it was in an empty stall and i couldn't
see it because it was covered by some
[ __ ] those chickens were sneaking in
there and laying eggs on that same
feeder that whole feeder had about two
dozen eggs in it with a chicken sitting
on top trying to hatch them all
that things have been there forever you
know just trying to
[ __ ] she was dreaming she didn't make
enough [ __ ] look at all the babies
[ __ ] is [ __ ] funny
because i didn't know what to do with
those eggs i had to throw all those eggs
out but i'd collect probably about a
dozen eggs a day huh you were there
yeah at least and that was at least and
and that and that was that was just the
ones you found that was the only ones i
found
and real quick you know in the barn they
had a refrigerator sitting in there and
i was stacking them eggs up in there
every day and you'd be like have like
[ __ ]
he must have three cases of eggs you
couldn't eat a bowl you couldn't use
that many aids you'd have to sell them
yeah
just free eggs
i fed them had to feed them some chicken
feed
but they were free-range chickens they
would have survived even without that
feed they were just eating bugs and
eating all kinds of [ __ ] yeah it was a
big piece of property big piece bro very
rural not as big as this one no but they
just like wandered around everywhere
like whatever and you know they some of
them get eaten but they they reproduce
so quickly you're like hey man it's an
extra chicken
who are you yeah
how'd you get hatched
you know
somebody hatched the chicken because you
know i had orders not to let them hatch
chickens but they're just you couldn't
stop them
there'd be an it'd be a chick sitting
there where the [ __ ] did you come from
what's up little baby chicken yeah do
you remember when at our old house there
was that farm like uh that was along the
path and they had a bunch of chickens
and those little chickens
would escape they liked to um they found
this little hole in the fence so they
like to go as a gang like all of them
they would go we're going under the wall
and they would go under the wall and
like wander around on the on the path
like looking at everybody like whew
we're out
so [ __ ] funny i was like oh look it's
a chicken gang yeah
[Laughter]
they busted out again until well i think
they eventually had the the fence fixed
like they figured out how they were
getting out but but that um
that uh
that farm where they're
growing those rabbits over there
that was a pony farm
at one time yeah so
they must've
ponies must have not been making any
money so he just went to food
which that's the future if he asked me
well i mean yeah i kind of feel like
well i mean ponies and horses and stuff
like that that's kind of like a more
luxury item luxury item um so you know
it's probably rich little little rich
girls yeah those little ponies
now if there's no fuel and [ __ ] horses
are the ultimate all-terrain vehicle
trail yeah you don't have to give them
any [ __ ]
there's only two things that will
survive the [ __ ] apocalypse the mad
max apocalypse
horses
and bmx bicycles yeah i was going to say
bicycle that would be my thing because
you don't have to feed a bicycle no and
they're silent yep and you have total
control over them of course you don't
really have a control the horse will try
to think for itself all the time you
know i could go cross country jump
fences i was in the hunter jumper
[ __ ] association since i was a little
kid you know i grew up riding horses my
mother was a california state champion
all right yeah his mom's a horse trainer
yeah pretty famous horse trainer in case
you didn't know
and uh
she uh
i was on the back of [ __ ] full-size
horses i was maybe five yeah little
bitty i got photographs of me little
bitty thing on a [ __ ] horse jumping
over a fence you were this big liz
i was like damn
little little bitty top yeah
but i'm good with a horse i can
jump
i could shoot from a bag of
horse um
i could probably shoot a bow from the
back of a horse
you know i'm a good archer too
but uh guns be no problem
ar-15 you just need a [ __ ] you just
have to have a horse that's
um used to the sound of [ __ ] rifle
shots which you can you can uh get them
used to it
you just put them next to a range and
over time they just get used to it then
you start shooting next to them and then
the next [ __ ] phase you get on top of
them start shooting
as long as they know nothing happens to
them they're okay with it yeah
tila says everyone should visit these
farms now fruit picking getting your
eggs hunted et cetera yeah the one they
pick up the road yeah they have peaches
and strawberries and oh there's a
blueberry farm up there too did you see
that one
i saw that one i saw that one yesterday
i'm sure they have other things too but
yeah it's a blueberry farm yeah and uh
most of the places have uh hives so they
have honey and most of them have eggs
because most of them keep chickens
because like you said chickens are
pretty inexpensive to keep these supply
chain disruptions are not by accident
all right they they're they're they're
being used as a tool and a weapon
against us
a weapon of control
but i looked into
it it's
what is being
we do not live in the world the people
that are thinking or trying to do this
this is like some bertrand russell
[ __ ] [ __ ] where
you know from 100 years ago of like well
we can get rid of these people and take
over basically what the nazis wanted you
know he says we can do it because
the poor people the working people need
our companies and our industries to
survive it's top down no it isn't it's
bottom up
those stores require supplies from
corporate sources
you get rid of those corporate sources
those stores will dry up
but if you actually look at the details
many of these states on a state level
have the ability to be food sufficient
or can conduct their own trade or they
can keep themselves alive if people
start growing food and trading and food
but you can't do that
in an urban environment that's the
problem
the people who are most at risks are are
people who are in an urban environment
is a powder keg they require
lines of supply
power they require a lot of stuff to
keep the city going it's a very fragile
system
um
and especially the way it was set up
with just-in-time delivery
it's not something that could survive
even the damn
uh
[ __ ] solar flare if a solar player
were to hit
and knock out power
for longer than three days those cities
will burn because the the food vanishes
there's only three days worth of food in
a city
if the deliveries aren't on time or are
[ __ ] up
if their uh uh the city starts to
[ __ ] go basically what you saw in
katrina which i saw that i was lucky i
wasn't in katrina i saw it from outside
in baton rouge oh man
um
i'm worried
i'm worried people
civilization is a delicate thing
it could very quickly go back to the
1800s but with technology with a very
high population without the technology
to feed that high population that's a
that's a very dangerous situation and
all this stuff well our military oh
we'll have foreign aid no all that [ __ ]
will disintegrate
the
totally incompetent
and the military of today is a shadow of
what it was when i was in in the 90s
it's just the quality is terrible
there's not very many people in it like
there used to be at small
um no talent all the good guys are gone
terrible [ __ ] chain of command the
officer chord general core is [ __ ]
terrible they're just
political generals
they don't have any skill
and i mean look what they did they
couldn't even handle afghanistan
so what makes you think they'd be able
to handle a [ __ ] heavily armed
[ __ ] population like like the south
now they get their asses tore out of
frame
you know they couldn't even beat a small
population of 85 iq dudes wearing
flip-flops and old [ __ ] aks with no
training they couldn't even handle them
they're never going to be able to deal
with a [ __ ] 100 iq average population
heavily armed with ar-15s and ak-47s a
lot of them with [ __ ] good military
experience
they won't be able to do it
it's not the way
it's not the way things happen
so i'm just
worried about this
[ __ ] thank you zach what's actually i
need a new job soon for more money but
mainly because the new boss there is
very hostile passive aggressive for no
reason no one likes her there oh that
sucks well i hope you can find a new one
um
somebody said oh camp guy said when a
rooster chases another rooster off a hen
he immediately mounts the same hen to
overwrite his dna over the other
roosters i think a lot of uh male
animals do that actually uh that's i
know for sure a lot of birds do i think
ducks might do that to you um
and then
tila said so much bulk stuff at costco
but it's just me the dude and the furry
babies we don't have the space to hoard
bulk stuff
yeah i mean
we have sams and i mean there's a costco
around here too but we don't go to that
one we have sam's and we probably go
what like once every couple months or
something yeah sam's one once every
month and a half we were saying
something like that and that's that
that's mostly just to get [ __ ] that we
use a lot of yeah big bulk stuff like
big things of coffee like big things of
flour flour sugar stuff like uh big big
cans of tomato sauce
uh cases of tomato paste stuff like that
yeah that we use stuff that you use to
cook with yeah um tina wants to know why
people are still procreating well it's a
myth that the earth has reached carrying
capacity
it's there isn't population problems
not really there's plenty of technology
to feed everybody
it's just that um
you ha you have people that don't want
that to happen
they don't want third world populations
they want the third world so the idea is
to collapse the third world so they can
go in there
and say oh it's terrible you know solar
flares and global warming killed all
these people so now we can take this
land that they used to occupy everything
is just reed bertrand russell man he
talks about it
it's the same thing the nazis do it's
just that everything is veiled and
hidden in
concepts like well democracy and
fairness and protecting the environment
and this everything is just a
camouflaged
way of doing colonialism globalism is
colonialism
to colonize the planet and it's our
oligarchs doing it from a concealed
position
with your minds being clouded
with uh ideas that aren't true they're
just words
that they can use on you so you feel
better about what it is they're making
you to do you know but no it's just
about it's it's the same thing they've
been doing since the 1800s
tammy says i grow stuff in flower pots
you would be surprised what you can
harvest from a small area lots of
youtube gardening channels we've been
started growing some broccoli
and you actually made a pizza today with
broccoli on it it was really really
gross
yeah
so we were growing a little bit of stuff
using mulch and then black cow
and uh spray insecticides
uh
and you kind of have to stock up on that
stuff here's the thing
a disaster that you're that if if it
[ __ ] got real disastrous
you
cannot you cannot hoard a lifetime's
worth of
food you just can't there's not enough
space for it
because you might live 20 or 30 years
if some kind of catastrophic occurrence
happened
if it's not resolved within three or
four years it's not going to be resolved
i think most of the problems would be
resolved within about a year or so
so i
you kind of want to be in a position
where you could survive for about a year
so
all right
and there's ways of doing that
but like i said in an urban environment
that's very difficult
because crime starts spiking
it starts to go kind of like katrina you
can't stay but you can't leave either
you won't have the money or the
resources to leave and then there would
be nowhere for you to go
because you'd have to fight your way
into new positions
and if it was catastrophic on a national
level a lot of towns would be locked
down they wouldn't let outsiders in it'd
go back to kind of like the 1800s
you'd have local
elected sheriffs and stuff
doing roadblocks checking ids to see if
you lived in that area
didn't they turn you around if you
didn't turn around they'd kill you on
the spot
it would not be the same world you
you're used
to this is already happening in some
places
in this area you know parts of mexico
are like that
you can't drive down certain roads
without a truck [ __ ] pulling up on
you dude's pointing guns that you saying
where are you going where are you going
and it's some cartel or something that
doesn't want you going down that road at
least not on that day
you're gonna start seeing things like
that
and it's because nature abhors a vacuum
the poorer the government gets the less
credibility it has is less ability for
it to get anything done
so
that vacuum is filled by
professionals and volunteers who are
local
so they'll be
they'll be local cops but other people
might call them local militias
which would be the same thing
it's just that they're being raised
locally they'd have uniforms
but they'd probably be kind of trained
quickly in an emergency type situation
and uh they might be under the command
of a local mayor or something
and
in that area
he's got the powers given to him by the
governor to basically do whatever he
wants because it'd be a it'd be an
emergency
and then everybody has their own idea
what an emergency is you know
but it's not going good man just telling
you people this isn't going good thank
you again zach here's a fun question
worst boss story
oh i know what mine is
that's that [ __ ]
jackhole that i worked for at that one
that dude he didn't do anything really
to me personally because like i said i
think he was afraid of me
but um
for some reason
but he was uh had some drug problems
and
he managed the place
it
belonged to his parents like his parents
owned it and like let him manage it
because i think they were trying to
get him to like get his [ __ ] together
um
and so he would
basically come in and he would take
money out of the
cash register
and then go you know
do whatever with it buy drugs i guess
and he would leave so little money in
there that the woman that worked the
front counter like a lot of times she
didn't have enough money like to make
change for people like if they needed a
change
so there was that uh and also he went
into these like really crazy like rages
you know what i mean it's like really
hard to explain but yeah he was like not
all there
uh yeah camp guy says costco is good for
dry goods peanut butter coffee bird seed
cooking oil yeah we get stuff like that
there like coffee creamer
uh cat litter garbage bags that kind of
[ __ ] you know what i mean yeah canned
stuff
now uh based on what you guys are
talking about the first peop the people
who are at the greatest risk
to of having bad things happen to them
in a time like this are the people who
are already in the greatest risk
it's about people who are
you know addicted to drugs
high crime area areas
uh people who depend on on ebt cards
single mothers
um people who depend upon government to
eat
and to
function uh because if that if that
vanishes there they immediately go
hungry they immediately start fighting
each other for food
just just like just like katrina
and if that were to happen at a national
level there's no telling what happened
some states of florida if that happened
to florida florida is
is in good enough condition to where
they could probably pick up the slack
where
people would still be taken care of
uh you know if people who are really not
mentally sound
i think they'd be all right in this
state but in other states there may not
be enough money or enough infrastructure
to make that happen
it would all depend on where you are
it'd all be a local problems
and each place would have its own set of
problems a lot of it based upon
geography
and what the population is like in that
area
the worst to be new england probably
because it's just so densely populated
a bunch of these little cities all close
to each other and it's so heavily
invested in
office jobs basically and banking you
know the
not a real well-diversified economy now
in those areas
tila and tammy are talking about uh
gardening and what is like the best
stuff to like grow on a like a deck
garden because tila wants to start one
of those
tomatoes are easy but there isn't much
isn't much uh
nutrition in a tomato there isn't much
nutrition in any of this stuff
um
probably when a camp comes to yield
i'm working on some pumpkins out there
pumpkins and melons
or big squashes that kind of stuff
you can get a lot out of that um but
they take they take a while
um
yeah i always felt like tomatoes were
easy i always thought green beans were
frilly i think they're fairly easy to
grow
yeah
yeah tammy says tomatoes are easy get
yourself some mixed greens as a lettuce
and then plant wheatgrass for the babies
so the animals don't eat it you know i
mean right because they'll eat your
plants
and you see there's no way to do
chickens
but what you could do in an apartment is
rabbits rabbits reproduce quickly they
don't smell that bad you can let them
run around
but the problem with rabbits is you're
going to get attached to rabbits if
you're living with them well yeah
i'd like like pets like i said i had a
pet rabbit when i was younger it's going
to be real difficult to cut that [ __ ]
pet's head off uh yeah
i'm not emotionally cold enough to to do
that to an animal um
unless it's obviously a food animal i
have to kind of be disconnected that
it's a food animal from before you know
and i can't do that to a person unless i
hate you and i have to be really fired
up there has to be a reason why i'm
cutting your head off
let's be obvious let's be honest yeah
you know what i mean i cut somebody's
head off [ __ ] right but i have to i
have to be convinced you deserve it
yeah you know yeah
i get it you got to be bad yeah
yeah you're going to be bad or you're
trying to hurt me or some or somebody my
family i'll [ __ ] kill you
and most people are like that
most functional people are like yeah
like i don't
say that they say they're not but you
put them under pressure they start
fighting back i'll [ __ ] kill you yeah
you know most healthy people will
that's just the survival instincts
protective instincts
yeah tila said i can't raise rabbits no
way yeah because you have to kill them
or you can give them to somebody else to
slaughter them but then all of a sudden
they give you your pet rabbits back and
you got to eat them yeah
so you know what i mean
yeah i could buy somebody else's rabbits
because those weren't my rabbits yeah i
didn't know those rabbits
i don't know you i don't know you
i mean i could probably eat rabbit if it
was like already
prepared you know what i mean like it
was already
they'd already skinned it and that's how
they give them to you that's what i mean
it's like if it still looks like a bunny
then i'm just no thanks
i'd be just like buying it from a store
yeah
but uh for a while i don't know i
remember when i was growing up you could
buy a rabbit in the grocery store
sometimes like they would have just like
a few packages of it i don't i haven't
seen it for a while though not like i
look but you got no problem killing
chickens
as long as it's fast
cut the chicken's heads ahead off
and chickens don't care if you kill
other chickens either so that that's the
acid test you could grab a chicken out
of a [ __ ] pack of chickens and cut
the chicken's head off straight in front
of all the other chickens and they go
right back to eating like it never even
happened
they won't even run from you
you just don't it's just not there's
just not enough brain power there for
some reason i think there there may have
been it's just that they've been raised
in captivity for so long that was
selected for over and over again in a
population
that the chickens are tolerant of
seeing
a tolerant of you cutting other chickens
heads off that doesn't doesn't seem to
bother me maybe there's kind of like
yeah i didn't like that chicken
yeah that's probably exactly what it is
yeah i got in the lake right now that's
the weird thing about pigs pigs have a
[ __ ] pretty good intelligence
but a domestic pig you can grab
the mama out
and
kill her in front of the other ones and
start cooking her and those pigs ask for
some meat
that's [ __ ] up yeah
it's not a normal intelligence things
are psychopaths
so there's like it does but then dude
that's your mom
some people go well they're boy they're
smarter than a dog i don't know i don't
think they are well it might be i think
they are but i think they it's there's
different types of it's right right if a
dog saw you do that to another dog that
dog would be whining and whimpering the
whole time
no no no no no yeah they'd be [ __ ]
they know what happened yeah but for
some reason domestic pigs don't seem to
don't seem to be bothered with about it
and i think they just kind of selected
through selective breeding that the ones
that are being
bred for food have
genetically passed that test of being
able to tolerate in other words they're
psychos
they're like psychos
yeah
they have some kind of psychopathic gene
we're like yeah [ __ ] her
she tastes good though
my mom's delicious yeah yeah
[Laughter]
kayla higgins says what does rabbit
taste like or deer kind of like a
rabbit
kind of tastes a little bit like chicken
but the
texture is a little bit more like
beef or pork
okay the texture is a little bit
different
but it
in general it's this the closest thing
to it is is chicken
chicken and i know that's very cliche to
say it tastes like chicken but it kind
of yeah the sizes of the pieces are the
leg quarter is similar to a chicken leg
quarter the shape of it
and the
the texture and the taste is similar
it's like chicken but instead you know
how chicken is kind of like a juicy meat
almost kind of like snake which you
don't know what that is but it's kind of
a juicy soft flaky yeah almost kind of
like fish
rabbit isn't like that it's got a
texture a little bit more like very
tender pork or
very tender beef kind of like veal kind
of like that the the texture the taste
is good
what'd she ask what was the other one
deer deer then is it
venison depends on what cut the best
cuts go along the damn back of the spine
or the filet which is kind of like the
flaming yawn cut that's uh and what you
do is you sear the outside of it
in a real hot pan and then you wrap the
fillet up inside that pan melt a stick
of butter in there put it on real real
low and just cut it cover it
and let it cook for about an hour and a
half on warm or like you know one
on your electric stove when you come
back it'll it'll be kind of done through
like a flame and you ought to be nice
it's kind of like uh
kind of like beef
um
now
the uh the roasts the hindquarters
it's a little bit
a little bit um
it's a little bit uh tough for you
it's a little tougher than beef
you just have to cook it okay you could
pressure cook it and make it nice and
tender or you can uh a slow roast it
there's all kinds of recipes for it's
very lean
that's why it's kind of tough so you
gotta be careful of how you cook it
um the front legs
you know this part
the shoulder and there's not much there
for meat
it's mostly hindquarters and fillet
there isn't even much on the neck
there's really
the ribs don't have much so you
it doesn't yield a whole lot of meat you
know they're only you know [ __ ] 100
something pounds maybe 100 pounds
you get a couple roasts about that big
two of those and a couple strips of
fillet about that long about that big
around get two of those out of it
um you just
but there's there's a skill to do
dealing with deer
that you can learn from um
just watch the predator
[Laughter]
you have noticed that a field dress get
the guts out of it make it easier to
carry
murder hornet says i know goat tastes
nasty although you know what i've had uh
goat curry go curry's good which is
actually very good but see goats are
also super cute yeah goats are
intelligent man they're more intelligent
than a dog they're a trip they got their
own little personalities and [ __ ]
they're funny
they're clowns
they are yeah goats are [ __ ] super
clownish
um
they're again it's gamey
so
goat is best with uh
or tends to be gaming
goats best with things that are like
indian type dishes where there's a lot
of spice in it
yeah because i've had goat curry like on
several occasions and it was actually
really really good it's kind of like
lamb kind of like mine yeah i like lamb
a lot too but yeah lamb can also tend
toward gaminess if you don't prepare it
correctly but if it's done right
like i said a lot of times in indian
food applications
like uh that memories of india has that
[ __ ]
that lamb korma that is out of this
[ __ ] world it's so [ __ ] good tila
says the most gamey thing i've eaten was
rattlesnake at the gilroy garlic
festival it was gross
it wasn't done right ran over to the
garlic ice cream after you take that the
garlic ice cream yeah i heard about that
and then they're talking about uh
fishing yeah and tila says i prefer fish
and seafood to regular meat i generally
do too honestly good good rattlesnake is
real close to like bluegill or perch or
white fish it's it's
light and flaky it shouldn't have a
gamey flavor to it i don't know what
they did we just it was just good with
salt lemon
fried butter salt and lemon
then tila says i'd like to grow some
portobello mushrooms if you throw those
on a grill and put between buns add some
cheese and it's stuff it tastes just as
good as a burger yeah i really do like a
portobello burger that's really nice
like those grilled portobello mushrooms
on them the problem with growing
vegetables is that vegetables do not
have much protein protein is the life
is the life-giving sustenance you need
protein without protein
you end up looking like a north korean
like a walking skeleton you have all
kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] up problems you
you can get
you can get some protein synthesis
happening with vegetables but
nowhere near as much as if it was with
meat so you're always going to have a
certain kind of like borderline
malnutrition kind of thing going on
depending on how much energy you're
outputting
you know if you're not doing much it may
be
it's not gonna be as bad but you'll end
up being like skinny fat probably
it's just it all just depends
now i mean if you're gonna grow food you
can just grow food that you want to eat
i mean you don't have to worry about
right you can just if you want now
in an application like what we're
talking about
a couple things that i could recommend
are the big things of whey protein that
bodybuilders use to make protein shakes
you can get five pounds of that
for about 35 delivered from amazon
depending on what flavor it is if you
can get a good deal on it sometimes you
can get it even better
that actually in an emergency situation
is a month's worth of protein for one
person
you could probably uh get it to last two
months if you were
light on it and you weren't really
running your body that hard
so you know for 35 bucks that's a
[ __ ]
months worth of decent protein
supplements so you can supplement
whatever
whatever the [ __ ] you're eating you
can supplement it with that
you know that's not a bad idea and you
can mix it with water or milk or
powdered milk uh that's another thing
those big old things of powdered milk
there's a lot of sustenance in those
um
as far as cheap [ __ ] that i saw
that i was like you know the nutrition
is not that bad um they those cans of um
chef boyardee ravioli with the beef
ravioli in the side with a
it's it's in a can and it's got a pull
top on it which meant means that
in world war ii they would have issued
that as a survivor as a ration right
along with spam
and you can get those for a dollar
imagine for you know so a hundred
dollars could get you 100 cans of
and it's pretty compact
that's about that might be a hundred
days
worth of [ __ ]
life
so for a couple hundred dollars three
four hundred dollars you could have a
year's worth
a [ __ ] protein
you'd get sick of eating that
you'd get sick the pro it's got a lot of
protein in it but not as much as protein
powder
but as far as something out of a can
that was a prepared meal that wasn't
that bad
uh for the price
probably also say that those vienna
sausages are kind of
okay for protein and stuff that's about
80 cents a can
you buy a couple cases of that
too bad they taste like ass yeah
but it's meat
another one is uh
cad's a beanie weenie
they had those in there ooh nice call
back um
to the beanie weenies yeah
so um
now
they're selling these
i think they're denting more plastic
single serving
it comes in a white plastic dish with a
[ __ ] yeah a lot of people take them
to yeah the office for their lunch yeah
well that's a remnant of that company
was trying to get a military um contract
to make the mres that is a mre
meal that was going to be in a package
that they were selling i've got a bunch
of them
the only thing i don't like about them
is there isn't a date on the bottom so
you got to write the date on there with
a magic marker before you take that
[ __ ] paper wrapper off because you
don't keep the paper wrapper
you take two of them you put it together
like that you duct tape them together to
make them even stronger you can put that
in a damn
backpack and it can survive punctures
the only thing i don't like about it is
that you can't put it in an engine
compartment or anything like that to
heat it up
you'd have to put it in a mess kit and
heat it up
um you may be dropping into some hot
water but doing that in the field takes
a long time so really what you can do is
just rip it and eat it cold
if you're gonna go through all that why
don't you just get a game can
cancer people think cans are heavy
they're not once that can's empty you
feel how light it is it's it's not much
heavier than a
plastic wrapper you know you can't
really tell the difference
you know
an empty can is kind of weightless
rodney says do you beat your meat with a
hammer before cooking it that that
sounded kind of talking about
he's talking about doing that to venison
probably we used to do it to some some
pieces of it you could hit it with a
[ __ ] meat tenderizer and then roll it
through a little bit of
egg wash and then
bread it with flour
and uh cook it or fry it and make um
really cold
chicken fried steak yeah then you put
country gravy on it
which you make out of
butter
um cream or milk
and then
flour and salt and pepper pour that over
white country gravy
real good
and what you do is you just
take a bowl of rice and you put your cut
you put your
your your chicken fried venison in there
or your fried venison steak on there and
then pour the damn country gravy over
the top of it and uh enjoy it and
and uh you know
get diabetes or uh get high cholesterol
yeah
that's why after a while yeah that's why
they're [ __ ] yeah
stardog78 said if i had to choose one
movie character to be partnered up with
in case of the apocalypse it would be
dick halloran from the shining he's
psychic plus he can cook
[Laughter]
and then tila says if you ever wait a
minute oh i know i lost it oh [ __ ]
i got so behind because i was trying to
like answer questions and
if you ever get invited to an african
wedding you'll be offered goat as the
main meal i think they do that um in
some place in india too because remember
we saw that uh that gordon ramsay thing
that he did and they like cooked a whole
goat
like for a wedding uh have we had
kangaroo meat yeah have you ever you
haven't had kangaroo meat no i've no
i've had wallaby
yeah
yeah i actually had it in beef jerky
wallaby jerky wallaby jerky i remember
there being like wasn't there kind of a
thing for a minute yeah and it was like
yeah in the 90s for like weird jerkies
it was weird like ostrich jerky and [ __ ]
like that everywhere
it was all coming from australia yeah it
was all australian stuff somebody said
that they tried that
that instant that powdered milk for the
first time to make stuff it was good
yeah
you can take
you can get it from walmart it's called
neato
and um
there's two different kinds the regular
one and fortified fortified is good
enough for babies you can you can you
can feed that to a child for a nursing
child
really i can't tell the difference
between the two
um
but you can make
milk and uh
you can just put it in the pitcher and
then refrigerate it and it comes out
pretty good
uh but the other day when i i made some
and just threw ice in it
and uh it was [ __ ] great you know
and it
it doesn't taste like milk out of a damn
carton you know but
it's it's it's a milk-like experience
you know that's because that's what he
kept having a bill click experience yeah
it's a meal
kind of like you know uh instant
breakfast drink or something like that
or like uh
kind of tastes like drinking coffee
creamer or something you know it's just
it's okay
but it's best for cooking
yeah because you don't have to store
milk and worry about it going bad if you
just need a cup of milk every now and
then for a recipe you can just
make it we used to get that powdered
coconut milk too from um from the indian
store yeah powdered coconut milk that's
just good because that's like weird
because coconut milk in a can is like
pretty pricey and it's expensive yeah
yeah so it's better to get the powdered
stuff from that because you get like a
big box and you can make a lot of
coconut milk yeah they sell that at like
indian food stores where they'll have
indian and pakistani and maybe
indonesian food all be sold into one
place as though they're usually placed
they're usually called like house of
spices or that's what our spices or some
[ __ ] how's those places that's the one
we usually go to yeah and you go in
there and then you'll find all different
kinds of rices and rice from you know
indonesia and india
now they have some stuff in there man
that's almost like an mre too
metal bags like an mre bag but they'd be
like um
sog paneer or [ __ ] chicken uh
chicken tikka
and the price was uh reasonable
and it'll last forever it's because a
lot of indian homes you know india's big
country and the average person is poor
they don't have refrigeration so
meals snack meals or just have to be
something like an mre and they just can
cut it and open it and heat it up maybe
they have a microwave maybe they don't
but it's a good little ration protein
was good for when i looked at them too
the nutrition was good
and they'd also have which i have some
of these because they were selling some
of them at publix i have them
um
bags of pre-made indian rice a couple
different flavors of that and then
indian um
uh uh
usually uh like
uh
vegetarian curries i got about four or
five
different versions of those i think i
paid like three dollars for each one of
them that's when i was making my own
mres
and i tried them they're good real good
there's no meat in them though so you'd
have to supplement it with protein
powder
gotta add protein
startup 78 said someone should do an
experiment on youtube i ate nothing but
beef ravioli vienna sausage and spam for
a year
[Laughter]
be better than starving
well nutrition would be pretty that's
pretty much true of anything right um
i'd like to try to see you live off of
pasta nothing but pasta and uh crackers
and uh uh [ __ ]
cans of corn
yeah no you'd be [ __ ] up after about a
year you have to have
you have that protein in there
here's another one that i found if you
guys ever heard goober grape it's a
[ __ ]
it's it's a it's a jar of peanut butter
and jelly in the same jar it's in
stripes
well the goober grape one comes is real
good
it's made by smuckers it comes in a
glass jar
so you can't carry anything like that
[ __ ] backpacking or survival or
anything it's gotta be plastic
well the generic version of it
tastes exactly the same they have that
here at dollar general store
for a dollar sixty
it's a jar twice that size that has the
peanut butter and the jelly in the same
jar
that would be pretty decent nutrition
for and and calories
now your bread
you can't really pack bread we tried it
in the army
um
so we packed crackers
but the crackers have to be in a can
so it's hard to find that maybe you
could throw round crackers in a damn
tennis ball can and stack them
but that would be
kind of impractical
i think would be better is to just to
take flour tortillas in a ziploc bag
when they come in and just roll them up
and pack that into a pack
and you can eat peanut butter and jelly
on on that
on a flour tortilla
and look that sounds crazy when you're
[ __ ] starving
marching all day especially if it's
[ __ ] cold or super hot
laying up in that hooch that you make
little poncho hooch just getting nestled
up inside your damn
sleeping bag just eating something like
that man you'll you think you're in a
[ __ ] five-star hotel
you would you will think that you're in
a five-star hotel your your standards
lower very quickly when you're living in
the field
at least they did for me
you know three or four days into your
first field exercise when i was a kid
and [ __ ] being poured on it rained on
because they [ __ ] choose the rainy
season they choose the worst possible
weather conditions to test the troops in
because they got to make sure everybody
can drive the trucks and the [ __ ]
supply lines can all [ __ ] handle the
punishment of [ __ ] extra cold weather
and [ __ ] so it's not just you out in the
field being tested it's also the support
networks being tested so they pick pick
the worst possible conditions all the
time
and you're just so miserable after three
or four days just to not move and to get
into a sleeping bag for a few hours man
you think you're in it in a heavenly
cloud of love
damage feels good
yeah
yeah well yeah i mean anything's like
that if you spend any
length of time doing something really
really unpleasant yeah then something
just as simple as like taking your shoes
off or something like that
it's like oh my god that's the best
thing ever yeah and then you hear the
rain hit the top of the poncho hooch
he said what's the poncho hooch
you take an army poncho
and this camouflage poncho and you
[ __ ] tie it's got a hood on you put
your hand you put your head through
where you take that you tie it
tie it closed
on the outside of the poncho it's got
snaps and it's got metal rings
you take five bungee cords you put one
bungee cord in each corner and you
stretch it between trees so it gets
tight you take the fifth one and you
wrap it around where the f where your
head your little [ __ ] hoodie comes
out you wrap it around there and you
pull that up and you hang that from a
branch so you make like a little
pyramid out of your
poncho you make it three feet off the
ground and you climb underneath there
and you throw down your little mat and
put your sleeping bag in there and now
you have an e-tool too which is a little
collapsible
shovel
and you start digging to level it and
then you want to make the dirt higher so
where your sleeping mat is going to be
it's going to be higher than everything
else so when it rains the water goes
around your sleeping bag not into your
sleeping bag there's all kinds of [ __ ]
you got to know
i have a [ __ ] living like a four-star
hotel i can make a four-star hotel
within about a half hour if you give me
if you give me a
five five five bungee cords a poncho and
a knee tool and a sleeping bag
and what we call a [ __ ] pad but you got
to be a [ __ ] to [ __ ] sleep on that
thing that's that's the roll out matt
i got a good one i got my [ __ ] good if i
whenever do my own channel maybe i'll
make a video and i'll put up on this
channel
of how to [ __ ] pack a ruck how to
live in the field everything you need
and what to get and what not to get
and what the use for everything is
that would be about 10 hours of material
it'll probably be about [ __ ] five
videos
well there you go yeah maybe i ought to
do it we'll put up on this channel
caitlin higgins says tom have you ever
slow roasted something over a fire like
rotisserie style if so do you have any
tips
um over an open fire no
um over open fire usually was cooking
things that were already in cans
or it was things like fish
and there's there's no reason to slow
roast fish because fish cooks very
quickly
um
what you can do with fish
it also depends on what you have at hand
if you do not have a frying pan which i
carry a frying pan in my mess kit
i'll show you what a mess kit looks like
it's two halves close together it has
cooking implements and stuff in it
it's a military mess kit
you want one of those
you also want knife spoon and fork and
they all fold up and they go into a
little mess thing
okay they come apart so you can have a
knife and a fork and a spoon
um
so eating implements
one of the things that you could do is
you could take a piece of
first of all you catch fish
you gut the fish cut the head off
don't scale it you usually don't have to
scale it if you do it uptown it depends
on what kind of fish it is
lay it
on a uh aluminum foil if you have
aluminum foil but usually you should
have something like aluminum foil or a
mess kit with you
and you can put that on top of the coals
in a fire
and it will cook just like that you can
flip it over let me get a drink like
one thing you can do is you can take the
fish and put it on the aluminum foil and
then fold the aluminum foil over it so
it's on the top and the bottom and you
just flip the whole thing it's like in
there the fish is in there
inside the aluminum foil and it'll cook
if the coals are hot enough we're
talking only like a few minutes five
five minutes maybe
and then you just open it up and there's
your cooked fish and just
usually you can just pull the skin right
off of it and all the [ __ ] scales
come off
and then you'll have a fish and then you
just [ __ ] pull
pull the meat off of the bones in the
direction that the bones go
there's all different ways to cook in
the field though
but they're all lengthy so be an
infantry you don't have time because
you're constantly moving they're feeding
you anyway they're sending you food
that's pre-cooked
uh you know mres
but when you're camping what you do that
grew up doing that in mississippi it's a
different deal you have time
to do things like cook fish
and if you're going to be out there for
months and months and months you're
living out there
so you're also living off the land going
where the fish are good the easiest
thing to do is catch fish that's the
easiest
and not rotten reel is one way but the
most efficient way is trotline
if you just get a rope tied across a
body of water and you have little
[ __ ] fishing lines descending into
the water every three feet with a hook
on the edge you don't even sometimes you
don't even need bait you can just put
the hook they'll just bite the hook
dummies yeah it's dangling so they bite
it
what's that oh
if it's something small
[Music]
and you're not going to eat it you can
kill that like a fish and cut it up into
pieces
and uh you know
if you're living in the field you in as
long as it's not too cold you just strip
down to your shorts and go out into the
water and bait the hooks out in the
water and then swim back up and then
just keep checking it every
twice a day or something you just go
down and [ __ ] grab the rope pull it
like that and see if there's any fish on
there and just put it back there's no
reason to waste time sitting there
fishing
you can also make crab traps very easy
and you just have to be in and have
ingenuity sometimes it's just
you find a damn big old can
you know and you go you know they'll go
through that hole and fall in that hole
and i'll just tie a rope here you know
i'll put some
put some bait in there and they'll go in
and i'll just pull up the crabs will be
in there
it doesn't have to fold up there's a
bunch of different ways to do it
you can go on youtube and see you know
primitive cultures do it all the time
they were even using things like [ __ ]
two-liter bottles
taylor says uh did we read into thin air
about the mount everest expedition i
haven't but i actually have been wanting
to because i heard that was a really
really good book yeah she said it was
great i will get around to it um
and tammy's talking about all the stuff
that she grows and she said this is
interesting tammy said uh she went to
college for landscaping and nursery
technology oh okay i was like oh that's
fascinating
i didn't i didn't even know that so she
like knows how to grow all the things
she'll be all right
tila said i remember as a kid going into
my uncle's army camping gear and he told
me to try the rations i would open a
candy bar eat a little and run to the
bathroom nasty
it's it's i don't know
for some reason i was like thinking of
that joke that you used to pull on your
siblings like back when you were kids
where you'd take the
chocolate laxatives
and give them okay you know here have a
piece of candy oh thanks how nice of you
ah
[Laughter]
do they even make like uh
laxatives that look like chocolate bars
anymore i don't even know
just because so many people got that
[ __ ] prac bold on them
i don't even i don't know i'm not up on
the i'm not up on what laxatives are
available do you remember those um
they weren't laxatives
but they were
what were they diet gum or something
like that remember it was called aids
yeah i remember that but it was a it was
a yds it wasn't it wasn't diet it wasn't
gum
it was diet something right it was diet
chocolate and okay yeah when i was a
little kid
somebody gave my mom got some of that
here have some aids it's called
a white it would aid you in your diet
yeah it was before the aids pandemic
yeah obviously
[Laughter]
and it came in a box that looked like
c's candy
and um you lifted the top of the box off
and you'd see all these little
chocolates they were like kind of like
you know those little ice cubes from
bear yeah they look like that yeah
it was this the waxiest almost horrible
[ __ ] tasting
thing ever it looked like chocolate but
didn't hardly taste anything like
chocolate
you're like oh my whole life is alive
mom put them up up top the refrigerator
i was a little kid and i climbed up
there to get to get to them well i was
climbing up there for some reason i saw
him like oh man candy
i started eating those things man
oh man it tastes terrible it was like
eating but when you're a little kid
you'll eat something that tastes
terrible and then you just keep eating
it
[Laughter]
i eat like four or five of them and what
they did was i think they [ __ ] kind
of expanded in your stomach and made you
feel full i think that's what they did
i'd have to look that up yeah
i think they were also kind of chewy a
little bit like it was like waxy and
hard but they were also kind of chewy a
little bit like terrible if i remember
correctly but the texture was just
terrible
yeah camp guy said you ate an aids bar
before a meal and it was supposed to
suppress your appetite so you wouldn't
eat as much yeah so yeah maybe it did
kind of like blow up and just blow up a
little bit expand in your stomach or
something like that yeah which
there's other things that would do that
too i don't know why the [ __ ]
yeah tammy said my mom tells the story
of my oldest brother getting into the
x-lax when he was just a toddler pooped
for days
[Laughter]
barry said as a kid i tried like
different milk bone dog biscuits i'll i
did that to you well um
i mean i knew that they were dog
biscuits but
they are so cute they look like little
bones and i was just kind of like i was
curious they didn't smell too good but i
was like maybe it tastes like a cookie
it didn't taste like a cookie
so it was like slim fast back in the
early thousands yeah well slim fast i
kind of feel like slim fast wasn't that
was more like a meal replacement though
right i kind of felt like wasn't slim
fast one that said shake for breakfast
shake for lunch and then have a normal
dinner because it was supposed to just
have like all your nutrients and not
have that many calories so i thought it
was more like a i thought it was
supposed to be like a meal replacement
rather than
something that you like
you know that would
you know make your appetite go away or
something like that yeah meal substitute
do they still make that do they still
mix them fast slim fast
i haven't seen it but it's not like i've
looked so i don't really know
uh john gore says i remember the bullion
cubes that were wrapped kind of like
chocolates as a kid yeah i remember that
too
and i don't know why i just thought of
this but you guys remember sucrets
that were like what were they cough
drops or
something or like cough medicine and
they came like in a tin that kind of
looked like it out like an altoids tin
now that i'm thinking about it and then
inside they were like wrapped in red
foil and i just think that red foil was
like the [ __ ] i thought that was so
pretty
it's like i always kind of like to go i
was a weird child i kind of liked a lot
of different like packaging
like if i thought packaging was
particularly cool or particularly pretty
even if i didn't like the actual thing
like i didn't need a secret i just like
to go in there and like look at it
because i thought the red foil was
pretty it was just kind of like
that um
oh [ __ ] what was that stuff it's just
like that underwood uh deviled ham
and it had it came like in the can but
the can was like wrapped in paper
and it had like a little red devil on it
and man i used to think that [ __ ] was so
cool i didn't like the deviled ham but
my grandmother always had some of it in
the cabinet and i would just like to go
in there in the cabinet and look at it
i'm like look it has a devil on it
that's so awesome
yeah tila said well now you can just
make yourself a smoothie and have that
for breakfast yeah that's what i mean
it's it's it is a lot healthier i feel
like because i don't know i don't even
know what was in slim fast for christ's
sake
but
yeah now i feel like most people just
make their own smoothies nowadays right
they just with kale and bananas or
whatever the hell you just kind of throw
it in there make it
uh i remember secrets i think for sore
throats yeah it's like every now and
then i'll see
like um
like a like an old movie like from the
60s or 70s or something and somebody
will like have
a tin of those like in the
in the bathroom and i'll be like oh man
i remember like the little red foil like
they were it was like a tin like an
altoids tin and they were like they were
about like that big like about a penny
size i think this is um i could be
remembering it totally wrong but then
they were just like laying in the bottom
of this tin like that and they had like
this red foil
and it was like and they were super
super cool
what did you get some stuff
i got those
it's a ham
it's a ham ham
that was only three yes it is
that was like only three three dollars
and 20 cents i bought them all
they had five i'm buying all year i
bought all of them but they never
restocked them
see well maybe you're the only one
that's buying them
yeah
see it has a pool cue it has a pull um
yeah thing on it so that's good
that's a ration then they had these for
a dollar
and actually the the
the nutrition on the back isn't that bad
and this is that peanut butter i was
telling you about
that was only uh i think three dollars
yeah because clover valley that's the
dollar generals
yeah i mean that's i think that's their
store brand and that's in a plastic jar
said to worry about breaking it
so uh camp guy says eat the can and all
right
so just get some iron there's [ __ ] out
there that's uh interesting
i'd imagine they were selling these for
a dollar
you could probably get a case of it
and it probably go down about 80 cents
and honestly of all the kind of canned
food like i don't mind that i don't buy
the uh chef boyardee it's actually it's
not the best thing ever but when you're
hungry man that's just who that's what
i'm saying like a few times when i used
to go into the office and there was a
7-eleven right next door and sometimes
i'd forget to take lunch with me
and so i'd go over there 7-11 and just
get a little i didn't get like one that
size i got like the one that was like a
little cup
and um yeah it was perfectly perfectly
good usually what happens with uh
those cans of ravioli i don't like the
lasagna i don't like the spaghetti some
people like the spaghetti i like the
spaghetti and meatballs and the ravioli
the other ones are kind of
usually what the problem is it was when
you open when you open the can
the sauce is slightly dehydrated it's
like a little thick
if you put it into a bowl and just add a
little bit of water to it it gets better
actually it loosens up i like it thicker
though because i kind of feel well that
was the reason that i never liked
spaghettios like the franco-american
stuff because i thought it was too runny
well when i was having those it was too
thick i'm not talking about a lot of
water i'm talking about a few drops of
water yeah you know not a lot just a few
drops and it'll it gets a little bit
better
and the same thing would happen with
mres mres are slightly dehydrated i
think they
i think they're kind of shy of water
when they cook them in the can as part
of the preservation
process
yeah if you add some water to it it kind
of
it tastes a little less canned i guess
that's the best way to put it
yeah straw 78 said i was a beef ravioli
fiend growing up yeah i pretty much i
like the beef ravioli especially like
the extra stuffed ones when they came
out with that and the spaghetti
meatballs my grandma always had them
because we always stayed at my grandma's
over the summer when we were out like
because she babysat us and she always
had tons and tons of chef boyardee there
and i had one for lunch like pretty much
every day for years and years you got
your glasses on read what the how many
calories per can how many protein how
much
serving size per can per can yeah is 320
calories that's not bad
and it's 425
25 grams is how much is in there okay
and how much protein
um
nine nine grams in the whole can in the
can okay that's not great but that's not
bad either some stuff has none and eight
grams of fat okay how much how much
carbohydrate um
52 grams yeah a lot of it's energy a lot
of calories yeah a lot of cat a lot of
energy but still the calories aren't
that bad 300 calories that's not that
bad yeah i mean you could eat this whole
can and that's like a reasonable
calorie
how many calories is the whole can the
whole can whole can of meat uh wait a
minute serving size two ounces okay so
this is supposed to be eight servings
eight servings they don't have a whole
cans worth then no it's 100 calories per
serving so this whole thing is what 800
calories got 800 calories is that what
they're telling okay that's a okay and
how much how much protein nine grams for
per serving per serving okay so two
ounces 90 grams more or less 90 grams of
protein for the whole can
yeah yeah because it's 10 right
times 10
yeah all right how much for eight no not
eight okay there's eight servings in
here okay
i love this it says to serve bristol ham
yeah to serve cold
remove bristol ham from can that's
important yeah yeah yeah don't just go
[Laughter]
slice for sandwiches or hors d'oeuvres
right thank you
in the military what we would do with
something like this is you'd put it over
a damn engine compartment of a machine
that was running and it would just heat
up heat up slowly
tila wants to know how much sodium is in
there probably a lot
uh oh
yeah
620 milligrams
that's 26 of your daily sodium intake
yeah for one serving for one serving
yeah
so this whole can is a salt bomb yeah
it's okay though yeah
it's got smoke flavoring yeah
yeah when you're um military or survival
uh situation uh you're not really
worried about what it is per daily this
and that because
in reality if you were by yourself you
would just eat all of this in one
setting because there's no way to store
it and you'd be happy that you ate that
you're like oh that was good you sit
around now later on a few hours later
you need something else
you know wouldn't have as much protein
in it you know
yeah some rice or something
somebody said uh
ramen's good too like a lot of ramen
recipes yeah we make a lot of um yeah
because ramen is really cheap and but
you can do a lot with you need to dress
them up like you cannot survive on ramen
well no i mean what i was gonna say was
that we were talking about recipes right
now necessarily talking about you know
yeah i'm just saying i really like ramen
with uh hard-boiled eggs
and vegetables vegetables in it it's
really really good yeah if you look if
you look uh if you look on the back of
the ramen you'll see that it has no
nutrition it has no nutritional value
you can start to death eating that has a
lot of calories yeah just calories but
you'd starve to death there's no
nutrition in it and tila said we have a
ton of packaged tuna yeah i like it i
like tuna yeah you can you can get that
in the dry packs or you can get it in
cayenne's in it yeah i got a bunch of
that and the chicken yeah we got lots of
canned
um but ramen ramen was really kind of
designed in japan right after post-war
they were having a problem getting
getting their hands on the rice that
they liked
uh the us was feeding them a bunch of
barley they didn't really like that so a
company came up with some way of making
instant noodles
and uh
from day one they were dressing those
instant noodles up
with things that the us government was
giving japan after the war the main
thing that they were getting was spam
spam and vegetables
so ramen was never designed to be eaten
on its own
um it just came with a flavor packet and
everything it was
it was uh
a futuristic food
of its time
i mean when i was broke like sometimes
for lunch i would just eat it like you
know with the flavor packet like just
eat it as a soup but it's much better if
you put if you tart it up with eggs and
stuff we took it to the field in korea
with you know but we just kind of ate it
as a soup and we threw stuff from the
mre we threw mre stuff in it
it's good with thinly sliced pork in it
as well because we've had it like that
also but my favorite thing to put in his
hard-boiled eggs yeah and like any kind
of veggies and stuff
yeah that's what david june said ramen
is a basis for a recipe it's not food in
itself yeah like i said when i was broke
and it's like because you know they were
what 10 cents or something yeah like you
just eat it as a soup because i didn't
have any money but um you know yeah it's
much better like it was a rice it was a
rice substitute yeah
the japanese you know i mean i actually
like noodles more than rice generally
yeah i like rice too but in certain
applications but if it's like a choice
between rice or noodles i'm usually
gonna go with the noodles you know
oh man all right
are we done yeah i guess we're done camp
guy says oh tuna salad yes celery apples
mayo mustard walnuts onion peppers just
yeah um
yeah we've made uh remember we made that
tuna salad one time with those green
apples in there
and nuts and stuff and it was and i
think there was crayon berries in there
too and that was like really really good
in a pinch now i've learned this man
from the [ __ ] service and a lot of
you guys are infinite some of you guys
are infantry
next infantry
it has to first of all you have to be
able to eat it on its own
it has to taste decent when it's frozen
like you you didn't set it sounds crazy
but sliced ham or like that that ham is
would we eat that same thing that came
in our mres it was just called ham slice
it was a big old [ __ ] ham slice got
an inch thick
we loved it in korea because it was good
frozen
because your your mres are all [ __ ]
frozen it's like a ham cichlid let's see
it 40 degrees below zero
in the winter uh so and you just and it
would crunch and it would have like a
nice easy
i heard eskimos describing [ __ ]
what whale blubber tasted like
and when it
frozen it was good when it was frozen
it's not good when it's heated up and
different things and you know exactly
what they're talking about there's a
certain texture meats get when they're
frozen some of them are good some of
them are bad
ham slice was good frozen another thing
that was good frozen was uh tuna and
noodles
some of you guys like what
yeah the tuna noodle mre i could see
that yeah it was it was it was wide egg
noodles
with tuna in it in a in a white cream
sauce i think it has some peas and green
peas in it yeah i think tuna that it
usually is yeah and then the mre
was a flat bag and when you ripped it
open you could you could push it up like
a popsicle
and it was thin wide
frozen thing of them
tenderness you can bite pieces of it off
and chew it and it was delicious when
you're [ __ ]
freezing cold and hungry
you wouldn't believe how good frozen
tuna noodles is it sounds disgusting
thinking about it now but it didn't
sound disgusting back then
it does but then when i thought about it
for a second i was like no you know what
that might be good it was real good
real good some of them weren't as good
frozen
like uh
uh what is it barbecued barbecued the
barbecued pork and rice it wasn't very
good frozen
um
kind of think about another one
uh okay the one that everybody hated was
chicken ala king chicken olive king was
better frozen than it was hot
because you couldn't taste it you
couldn't taste it as well but you
couldn't say it yeah
chicken on king didn't have a bad taste
it just um
was very generic it was just a 1980s
white
you know yeah i remember back in 1980s
if it was white it just all white gravy
just like not terrible but they all just
kind of tasted
bland like they don't really taste like
much of it yeah white stuff
yeah
yeah white gravy
you know
i was thinking like kind of like okay
you know what it kind of tastes like
kind of tastes like camels mushroom
camel soup but even more bland
yeah that's what i was imagining yeah i
was gonna say uh also ramen noodles this
is another weird thing that i like to do
every now and then
i take the ramen noodles and kind of
crunch them up a little bit and i put
them in you know progreso makes that
manhattan clam chowder soup like in the
can yeah and i
put and i heat up the can of the soup in
the in a pan and i put the ramen noodles
in it so it thickens the soup up and
it's actually really really good it's
good in the chicken noodle too but i
think it's better in the manhattan clam
chowder
but the chicken noodles are right uh
blair dude said i have to check out
these dollar general dollar tree food
challenges thanks jenny yeah there's a
bunch of different channels that do them
there's one girl uh what's her what's
her name
i think her name is that lisa dawn or
something like that then there's one
called frugal fit mom
and stuff like that but yeah just do
something like dollar tree grocery
challenge or something like that there's
like a bunch of different people doing
them
and i don't know why i got i don't even
remember how i started watching them but
i actually got really fascinated with
how they can
spend ten dollars at dollar tree and
like and then they show you like what
they got you know they got 10 things and
then they
make meals like all week for one person
i had a bad feeling man today
was up there publix and i'm sitting
there looking at the damn
[ __ ] pipe pepperoni
and next to the pepperoni with dried
bacon bits and they got a woman standing
next to me she's about 50
looking at it she's a little country
munchkin
and she goes boy damn bacon bits they
want a lot of money for them and i'm
saying i know and i said i got a bad
feeling about this he goes yeah me too
this is too expensive and it was just
like and and it's and i said yeah this
is new york prices
and this is this is florida income with
new york prices goes yeah if you can
find it
and
she was thinking the same thing i was
thinking the variety just wasn't there
the foods that you took for granted just
aren't there
and we're in florida this is the best
case situation
now if you go to multiple stores you
might find it it's just that the
convenience of it being in this in one
store is not there anymore which is
there's some disorganization going on i
want to go look at down walmart and see
what
what's where is the where is even the
closest walmart around go down here and
you go down to light and then turn left
it's over there near where the lowe's is
oh okay oh yeah
i know what you're talking about yeah
okay so i want to go to that's not super
far and see what's going on at walmart
uh but then going to that dollar general
store you'd find good deals like this
yeah yeah they have a can of ham it's
like sometimes they you know they don't
have some stuff like that they'll be
like like empty shelves but then
sometimes you're like actually surprised
at the [ __ ] you can find in there if
this was at publix they'd probably want
five for it
for the same thing
yeah so um you it's not like it was
where everything's centralized in one
convenient place
and then up the road i got a guy got a
guy selling skinned rabbits
and now you pick [ __ ] vegetables and
[ __ ]
so it's i'm in a good situation so i'm
trying to extrapolate but i bet you it's
bad in certain areas here in the u.s
when it comes to [ __ ]
trying to find a specific food item
yeah depending on where you and i bet
you it's all local all depends on where
you are and what the situation is in
that area i mean i feel like most of the
time man we were spoiled back in the way
it was where you could get anything you
wanted anywhere at any time i kind of
feel like we haven't had too much
trouble around here i mean between
the closest things the dollar general is
like right there like right next to our
neighborhood and then about a mile up
the road there's a publix yeah and
between those two places we can find
most things yeah but then i went over
there and look at it i was looking at um
a dozen large grade a eggs
at publix
they wanted like three dollars and forty
cents for a dozen eggs
when just about a month ago
that was about a dollar twenty five
a matter of fact looking back
a couple years ago that wasn't even a
dollar about 97 maybe a dollar
for a dozen eggs
it's not good
well it's not like there's anything i
can do about it now there's nothing to
do about it just saying
pookie it's not good pookie she's
looking to go i know it's not good she's
always this little white black and white
striped [ __ ]
the little mouse mouse but yeah she's
always got one in her hand where's the
black and white striped ones
she likes all of the all of the mouseys
but i think the black and white striped
ones are her favorite we thought maybe
it was because she could see it better
because of the contrast yeah
she's always she picks it up by the tail
and shakes it around picks it up and
throws it and [ __ ] like that it's like
super funny yeah we're talking about
these
yeah
these yeah yeah she loves little mouthy
yeah the auntie elsa's hat is that those
i think
they call in the yeah thing well now i'm
getting cold again
okay i can't let's got that fan on i
know
all right people i guess we'll get back
to more or less unless they got any
questions or they still talking yeah i
think because i'm getting kind of sleepy
all right i got because like i said i'm
still hungover so i did actually i well
i'd never do this i woke up this morning
at my usual time i don't even remember
what time it was we got home last night
it was like it was late
and i went right to sleep and then i
woke up in my usual time which was like
7 30
and i was like well [ __ ] i guess i'm
awake and i got up and i made a cup of
coffee and had a cup of coffee and a
granola bar and farted around the
computer for five minutes five to ten
minutes and then i was just kind of like
you know what i'm so tired so i just
went back to bed and then i slept to
like 11 o'clock which i've never done
but it's just i'm glad i did but
because i would have probably felt even
worse
than i do right now
um but i don't feel terrible i'm just
like really really tired
so tonight we're gonna have to figure
out a movie to watch yeah that we can
talk about tomorrow yeah
and uh so that'll be good but this was
fun doing the side tracks yeah i just
figured you know we didn't have a movie
to talk about so [ __ ] it
we'll just talk about whatever
um you know all right so uh anyway
thanks everybody for dropping by and
hanging out on this sunday with us have
a good rest of your weekend
and uh we'll see you guys again tomorrow
evening
bye